I identify as a mexican-american Latino
Chicano I identify as latina Colombian I
identified as Latin X afro Dominican
black Dominican for latina I think it's
so funny though when people try to put
in boxes what type of latina you are I'm
like technically I'm Latin X I'm also a
Hispanic lady latina Portola kenya yo
sabe de todo Pepito I'm proud of my
culture because it's so rich in so many
ways
history in the values that it has also
has great food and great music and
pinatas and a lot of things that are fun
and have added a lot of life here in the
United States being latina means that
there is a story to my my heritage it
means that there is a big history behind
Who I am behind who my family is the
reason why we are where we are and who
we are in this country is connected to
being a Latina as a half Puerto Rican
girl who grew up in Miami I feel like
I'm so thankful that my mom made me go
support the pickup every single summer
and spend time with my family and really
dive into my roots and who I am and
everything about me is because of that
the music my food my passion how I
express myself the love and kindness
that I think I give to the world that
really is such a part of the essence of
the Latino culture I grew up in a
single-parent household my mom was
raising my brother and me and taking
care of her mom my grandmother we grew
up in neighborhoods that were still
dealing with the legacy of segregation
and in schools that were underfunded my
brother and I became the first in our
family to go to graduate school we went
to law school and then to become
professionals and then public servants
so we struggle through that adversity
but made it through and that's part of
reaching the American dream during Pablo
Escobar's era in managing Colombia which
is the reason why me and my
family my family and I came to this
country I was held at gunpoint at a
really young age and I think that was
just one of many incidents there was a
bomb that went off right next to my
parents when I was 8 months old and so
all of that terrorizing fear really led
my parents to come to this country
people in my community are willing to
make the lethal and they're deadly and
the dangerous journey to come here to
the US just as my parents did to give
opportunities for their children and for
their families my dad is an undocumented
immigrant from Mexico and my mom is an
undocumented immigrant who fled war I
heard a lot of things about my parents
saying that what they did was wrong and
in that way they're invalidating
my whole being because they came here
for me everyone has their own story of
what it means to be a black Latina like
there's the obvious definition that
people might use like a black person of
Latin American descent but for me it's
me being someone who came from a
two-parent household raised you know
going to school in addition to
connecting very much so with the black
American community as well as the
Caribbean community as well as the
African community and I just think that
it's an amazing thing that I can say
that I have all these influences that
make up Who I am and yet I can still be
proud of being a black latina and like
no one can take that away from me it's
definitely an opportunity and a blessing
and a privilege to be a part of the
United States of America I can't wait
for my Mexican Colombian kids to one day
be able to hear their stories of their
father and their mother and how our
stories as immigrants came about so
that's the beauty of America that's the
beauty of diversity and and that's what
makes me so proud to be a Latina